Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
review video for the batman movie with robert
pattinson and matt reeves there's so much stuff
to talk about so be sure to go see it when you
have the opportunity we're gonna be talking a
lot about batman in the next couple of weeks
i am doing a giveaway for movie tickets all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
leave your favorite batman moment from any
movie on the video if you do have a chance
to see the movie early please do not post spoilers
in this video before this weekend before the movie
actually comes out but the batman movie with matt
reeves is meant to be sort of a reimagining of the
character in a slightly separate universe from the
dceu you've all probably heard about how this is
not connected to a lot of the other dc movies
that have come before matt reeves is trying to
create a totally new universe for batman in his
sort of rogues gallery of villains and characters
that he'll continue on with hbo spin-off series in
batman movie sequels there are a lot of things in
the movie that feel similar to other batman movies
obviously it's the same group of characters that
you've seen several times before but the way
matt reeves approaches everything the way the
actors play everything is very different it feels
very different from any of the batman movies that
have come before but long time batman fans that
have been through like seven different versions
of batman will notice a lot of similarities in
nods to other batman films and classic comic book
stories it's a lot like david fincher's seven done
with the batman characters mixed with a little bit
of batman the long halloween from the comics
as well as batman ego is a very psychological
film but not in the funny joel schumacher way
like he doesn't sit down for psychoanalysis
in the way that chase meridian analyzes batman
and then they start doing it with each other
there are no nipples on his suit there are no
batman credit cards in this movie although i do
have a fondness for jim carrey's version of the
riddler this is a much more serious approach to
batman it's almost like a batman horror film like
give me horror film but with batman characters
just talking a little bit about the differences
between matt reeve's approach to the universe the
characters then christopher nolan zack snyder's
even tim burton's approach to the characters what
really distinguishes this film from a lot of the
best batman films that have come before is that
matt reeves really wanted to approach everything
from a neo-noir detective thriller aspect he said
that he started out with like a four-hour cut of
the film and the thing early on that hooked a lot
of the test audiences you always hear about test
audiences was the detective riddle solving aspect
of the film so it truly is a world's greatest
detective batman film like you've never seen
before like during the christopher nolan films
christian bale's batman did solve mysteries but
it was much more of a big action thriller type of
film it's the same thing with ben affleck's batman
much more of a giant adventure film matt reeves
tries to give it a very real world approach the
same way that christopher nolan did but with
a very heightened gothic look to everything
imagine if tim burton's batman movies had a
baby with christopher nolan's batman movies
like the look and feel of the bat cave the bat
cave is inside this abandoned subway terminal
called the wayne terminus it's literally the
subway terminal created by batman's ancestors
so it does feel very real but very dark and
gothic inspired like a lot of tim burton's
batman universe but whereas tim burton's batman
movies had this very heightened arch version of
reality like where did he get those wonderful toys
version of batman batman in this movie does have a
lot of wonderful toys but everything in this movie
the way the characters act the clothes they wear
the tech the batman uses even the batmobile
feels like something that real people could
actually create if they had a little bit of money
in some cases like the catwoman people who do not
have money a costume for instance that they could
create on their own everything feels very batman
but very homemade even though this is very early
in batman's career and they do address his origin
story they don't redo the origin story in the
same way that all the previous batman movies
have had a version of that crime alley scene with
his parents being killed by joe chill we've seen
thomas and martha wayne killed so many times it's
one of the reasons why matt reeves said that he
wanted to swerve on that and make it batman year
two instead of setting this during batman year one
like he didn't want to remake batman begins and
it does not feel like a remake of batman begins
you get a much better sense for what batman
is like after he's tried to be batman for
the previous year like he's been batman for about
a year when this picks up but in the way things
slowly escalate through a lot of batman films
like batman becomes batman puts the cowl on
starts getting rid of a lot of the powerful
corrupt figures sort of leaving this power vacuum
where a lot of his classic rogues gallery of
villains then start to rise up to fill that vacuum
matt reeve said one of the other things that
really excited him about setting this during
batman year two was allowing him to do origin
stories for a lot of the villains focusing
specifically on the villains obviously batman
is the main character but a lot of the classic
rogues gallery are just as big characters as
batman namely paul dino's version of the riddler
the penguin and catwoman there's been a lot
of talk about the run time of the film like i
mentioned matt reese said that he started with a
four hour cut i would love to see that four hour
cut of the film the theatrical cut comes in right
around three hours i love long movies i have zero
problems with that i thought the longer version
of the snyder cut made justice league way better
so i'm all in on longer movies there has been
a lot of talk about some of the deleted scenes
that matt reeves said that he might release after
the movie comes out you might actually see them
online there was a big tag scene at the end of the
film with barry kyogen's character that he deleted
he actually kind of explained what happened during
that deleted scene so because he is releasing it
online they might change that character for
potential sequels or the spin-off movies so
i am excited to see what happens with that just in
terms of where this takes place in the multiverse
matt reeves said that it takes place on earth 2
there is a dc multiverse that they're building
with the flash movie so technically everything
is canon to the dc eu but only technically the
way matt reeves explained it is that he never
plans to introduce an actual superman character
for instance or super powered individuals into
this batman universe of robert pattinson movies
make sure you wait to see the film before you
get upset about that because dc does have plans
for batman crossing over with other characters
i'll talk about that at the end of the video too
because dc does want to do more justice league
films eventually more crossover films with the
batman character and the other major dc characters
but for now at least the batman that will cross
over will not be robert pattinson's batman i
thought robert pattinson was amazing as batman
and bruce wayne i will talk about differences
between the way he approaches the character versus
the other versions of batman like ben affleck
or christian bale even michael keaton's approach
to the batman character i think when a lot of
people heard that robert pattinson was cast as
batman they just thought of him as the millennial
batman in a lot of the casuals a lot of the people
who aren't really big fans of film or just movies
in general haven't really bothered to see any of
robert pattinson's non-blockbuster movies so like
they only know him from the harry potter films as
cedric diggory or they've only seen him in the
twilight films i will encourage you to go out
and watch some of robert pattinson's more recent
indie films because he tears it up he's actually a
fairly amazing actor all the stuff he's been doing
the last several years since he stopped doing a
lot of the big blockbuster films is amazing so
most of the people making those batman sparkles
jokes are just people who do not watch indie
film or just haven't seen any of his other stuff
do not listen to them he is fantastic in this
movie one of the things that's really different
about the way they approach batman during the
film the way he approaches him is that he has
less dialogue than almost any version of batman
that you've seen before and i think that just
adds a lot to his mystery and the way he inspires
fear in a lot of other people the way he enters
scenes the way that other people perceive him it
all just adds a lot to the tear that is batman
is a little bit like the way they approach the din
jaron mandalorian character during the mandalorian
season one when they're introducing him the less
dialogue they have the more fearsome they seem
at this point in his career this version of batman
is still kind of running around gotham city trying
to solve crimes make things better searching for
his identity as batman just as the villains are
all searching for their identity too like oswald
cobblepot is a low-ranking member of the carmine
falcone crime family he's not totally sure where
he fits into everything in the power structure
each different actor different batman franchise
is a different way of approaching the batman voice
robert pattinson does not use any special tech
like ben affleck did to create the batman voice
but it's a little more down to earth a little
more realistic a little more subtle than christian
bale's batman voice this version of the batman
suit all of his weapons his gear his tech feels
like it could have been built by a billionaire
and his butler inside their garage i loved andy
circus's younger version of alfred in this movie
he feels much less like a father figure to bruce
wayne than previous versions of the character
he's much more of a partner than he is like a
father figure jeffrey wright plays a much younger
version of gordon he's still detective gordon he's
amazing in pretty much everything that he does
so no big surprise there during the movie he has
a sort of loose partnership that he's formed with
batman over the events of batman year one so when
the movie picks up he's already been working
with batman as an ally and obviously we have
to talk about the villains you can't talk about a
batman movie without talking about the villains i
feel like everybody delivers a really interesting
performance paul dano's version of edward nashton
the riddler is sort of like a zodiac killer
version of the riddler and he even kind of
physically looks like his costume looks like the
zodiac killer's costume even though he's this
crazy serial killer version of the character
he still feels much more real world much more
subtle than jim carrey's version of the riddler
even though i do have a soft spot for his version
of the character colin farrell is amazing as the
penguin he's unrecognizable i remember when the
first trailer dropped people like where's colin
farrell is that supposed to be the penguin who's
that character he's sort of like the tony montana
scarface of the batman universe the next big story
they're doing is a big spin-off series on hbo for
his character even though he really goes over the
top with his character it's still a little more
subtle than danny devito's version of the penguin
the penguin nickname is treated more as a
derogatory term at oswa cobblepot's character
and he himself really really does not like it
zoe kravitz is now my second favorite version
of selena kyle catwoman she did an amazing job
in the film but i still think that michelle
pfeiffer's version of selena kyle catwoman is
the definitive version just like all the other
characters in this film she gets her origin story
she feels much more subtle much more real world
than a lot of the previous versions the tim burton
versions of the characters we had to talk about
the music too music is such a big part of all the
batman movies michael giaccino does an amazing
job there's so many iconic batman themes from the
different franchises like the danny elfman theme
from the tim burton era of batman movies you have
hans zimmer's music from the dark knight trilogy
michael giaccino somehow manages to make the
music in this movie feel totally different yet
very familiar at the same time so i can't wait
till they release it on vinyl and i can add to my
collection they have been releasing a lot of the
tracks on spotify and other streaming services so
you probably had a chance to listen to some of
the music already overall i just felt like the
movie was fantastic i can't wait to see what matt
reeves does in this universe next like i said they
have the penguin hbo spin-off series there are a
couple other hbo series that they're working on
but after watching the movie once here's my
new ranking of batman movies and i'm not going
to include all the spin-off films like i won't
include that crazy halle berry catwoman movie or
all the animated movies but going from least
favorite to most favorite it's batman and robin
at the bottom batman forever batman v superman
batman returns with michael keaton the dark knight
rises then batman 1989 with michael keaton
then batman mask of the phantasm even though
it's animated it's still one of the best batman
movies of all time so i had to put it on this list
and then the batman movie with robert pattinson is
just a very close second to the dark knight maybe
it'll eventually win out as my current favorite
after a couple more re-watches i've only seen
the movie once as i'm making this video there
is a small post-credit scene tag scene at the
end of the film so be sure to stay through the
credits it's not quite what you expect but yes
stick around i'll do a video for the post credits
scene after the movie comes out in theaters later
this week then i'll do a full breakdown easter
eggs video in other more spoilery videos for
aspects of the film leave all your batman video
requests your big questions in the comments and
i'll try to add them to my list everyone click
here for my other batman video to learn about
what's going on with the sequel movies and click
here for my new doctor strange 2 superior iron
man video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!